Larry what brings you to story Expo 2014
I'm recognizing and and also pitching a
film in the TV series that I have a
feature film and a TV series basically
I'm pitching a character and the
character is in the movie in the
character is also the star of the series
Emma Dimas so I'm here to also see what
their what they're looking for and if
anybody is looking for something that's
a little offbeat which they're not I
mean generally so I'm trying to find out
what's going on on the other side of the
camera you know I'm kind of explored
acting I want to explore writing and
filmmaking
I wanna make my own films eventually
which I've been doing actually and how
long have you been working on this
specific idea 10 years 10 years okay
well I mean I've been working on the
character for 10 years I've been filming
him for 10 years in writing for 10 years
in different places sometimes I had a
show now I started out with it with a
show actually my sister
strangely enough sent me a sketch I made
in 1976 of a character named Emmett who
was an old guy you know and this
character Emmett that I'm here to pitch
is an old guy so I guess I've been
thinking about him since 1976 that's
really weird and because I've been
working as an actor he's looking for
work or actually working or trying to
memorize lines I I don't have much time
to actually become a filmmaker I have
ADHD so I can only think of maybe 10
things at once and so I took a
sabbatical about a year ago and I just
said okay I'm just gonna work on
filmmaking so I have these three film
three mature films that I did about
Emmett and they won prizes all over the
all over the world actually
and they're in festivals and stuff and I
thought okay I think I'm ready to write
the feature and act as in it so that's
where that's why I'm here but why now
have you had Emmet in your mind since
thank you well I think I'm old enough to
do him now and I've also figured out how
to write him in the long form you know
film shorts they're there ten minutes is
not long enough for me to develop what I
want to develop about him because I'm
it's a comedy and he's a comic character
like like Chaplin or like Louie CK
but you have to really know a character
at least in in my way of thinking and I
think I've made enough film shorts about
him and learned enough about the arc of
character and stuff like that so that
that's why now I feel I'm ready for some
reason I don't know there's a voice
inside of me said okay do it now I mean
nobody told me to do it and the voices
don't say anything back they they said
go floor those are good voices and why
do you feel that Oh may I know everybody
says no don't do anything ever about
anything ever
I mean that's just how the universe the
human universe talks the other universe
is pretty cool it says go for it if you
see what I'm saying I do and what what
do you think the reasons behind the
human universe nobody wants you to
change because if you change and they're
not it's on them
so let's everybody just stay the same
and we'll all be in our comfort zone and
let's not talk about it ok that's good
we won't so I just you know when you one
one day some people wake up to that fact
and I woke up you know about I guess
about three or four years ago I got you
know that boy started saying hey man
now I'm gonna just do this and they go
no you're such a good actor why don't
you just keep acting you know they say
now I want to be a filmmaker that's what
I say that's what the voices say but
people say yeah but don't you know
you're such we love you in like your
agent you know things like that
why do you feel that Emmet is too
non-mainstream or whatever the word is
many times well so far I've been
pitching and that's the they said he's
kind of quirky that's what you get
that's that's what I've been getting
well he's he's kind of quirky and he is
he's totally quirky I mean you know just
like louis c.k is quirky or Chaplin is
quirky or you know any other funny Adam
Sandler's pretty quirky you know but
that shouldn't matter it never does I
mean you know the first guy is always
weird you know subscribe we're doing it
whatever well what are the notes that
you've gotten cuz you'd already pitched
today or no you yeah notes are well we
were kind of we're looking for something
more grounded we're looking for
something what's kind of quirky I mean
we make a lot of stuff for hallmark so I
like it I mean I really do but I don't
know if I you know I don't think we
would do something like this basically
so what I'm hearing is he's too funny
that's that's the one of the message-id
yet
I come from you know second city I come
from the committee I come from you know
Charlie Chaplin Louie CK Bob Dylan
you know the Lenny Bruce you know Lenny
Bruce was too quirky I'm Dylan was too
quirky they were all too quirky anybody
who's funny is basically started out too
quirky you know yeah is there a way in
your mind you could tone M it down ah
there you go they're tones that would
kill him
no I mean I've tried it other ways it's
not me I mean you know I would rather
this is so cliche but I would rather do
it my way at least I know that when you
turn me down it's something that I
wanted to do it's something that I did
sincerely and it's not for you I could
that's cool
but if I do it your way and you turned
me down um EFT because what did I learn
I didn't learn anything by that you know
so I'm also a student you know so I got
to get something out of it no so if I do
it my way and you give me an O I've
learned something if I do it your way
and I get a no I've learned nothing I
think Larry how much time did you have
to pitch today five minutes which it's
really funny I mean that's that's just a
psychological thing because the first
time I kissed I mean first guy I pitched
to we said 10 o'clock this morning and
it was the first pitch and you know I
hadn't pitched anybody you have been
rehearsing it at home and you know
thinking about it I've been talking
about it with friends and stuff but when
it becomes official you know it's your
first pitch so I felt very rushed and
you know I didn't think I said it the
right way but about about the third or
fourth one I sort of settle down then
five minutes is plenty of time you know
because I got my story straight and I
you know so that's the other thing that
I'm here for and and that is actually to
learn how to pitch I mean literally and
that that's very conscious I again I
learned something you know I I think I
have 11 or 12 pitches that I've signed
up for it I may have more later but and
I thought okay what what happens if
nobody buys my picture nobody wants to
read my stuff okay then I got to work on
my teach maybe
but I think that what I did and you know
people have read it and I also have
reviews of the show I I also did a and
have a theater show about Emmet about
this character that I want to make the
movie about it got rave reviews in the
LA Times so I had the affirmation that
I'm on the right track and the film
shorts have made about Emmet have won
prizes I've gotten you know an Academy
Award nomination for films that I've
done so I don't need that but maybe I'm
not getting across that could be but
again if I did it your way I wouldn't
learn that well what's your first step
in writing a screenplay what would what
do you do whether it's Emmett's
character I have to it's the hard way I
have to be moved you know I can't just
I'm not a writer per se you know III I
can't you can't hire me as a writer I I
it would be hard for me because I had no
Emmet so well and then things happen in
the news or to me and I go wow this is
this is a great Emmet story right here I
live in my car for a year I mean as a
years ago when I was much younger but I
was homeless for a year and Emmet is
homeless I also was a biker for it for a
long time you know crashed and all that
stuff that bikers do so I know about
motorcycles and he's a he's done Tod on
the motorcycle basically that's the film
that's what the film is about and some
but I know about it you know if you
asked me to write about hijacking
Somalia you know hijacking boats and
stuff I would have to do a lot of
research and reading but I you know all
my life has been kind of researched for
Emmet you know he's very familiar to me
and so I write what comes up right now I
what I'm doing is trying to learn
pitching and raise money for for the
feature or for a TV series so that's
what I'm doing now I'm learning how to
do that how do you raise money
pitching is one way you pitch to the
studios I'm gonna have to pitch to my
uncle
you know later so um that's what I'm
learning here so you know and when my
sister and you know it's a process going
back to that year that you lived in your
car mm-hmm what what Schumer could you
bring to it oh man are you kidding where
do you go to the bathroom you know well
where do you where do you where do you
take a shower you know you start the
friends and Friends why'd ya why is he
coming here all the time rusty can you
take a shower somewhere else and you
hear these conversations you know in the
next room you know and you say okay well
I'm well worn out my invitation here you
know what McDonald's will let you use
their bathroom how do you get phone
messages you know where do you park at
night when you're living in your car
when you leave your car and you come
back at night your battery is gone
there's I mean a lot of adventures you
know and I watched Charlie Chaplin and I
go yeah that guy was that that guy was I
don't know if he was homeless but he was
poor
that guy was poor why there's just a
sense of that guy knows more about being
a homeless guy about about trying to get
a job then normal because he was there
and he did it
so there's an inner there's a voice
there's a truth to to living it and if
you can live it and tell about it it's
generally the worst turns to laughter
that's that's Shakespeare that's true
I mean the worst things that happened to
me are now funny but they weren't when I
was going through it you know I mean you
come back to your car and your guitar is
stole and that's like a tragedy man you
wait you're gonna get another good
that's my guitar it keeps me cool you
know just your battery is gone how am I
gonna move the car I got to get it to
the other side of the street on
Thursdays I mean that stuff becomes
funny and telling about it but when you
tell about it people know that you did
it
you know you were you were there
and that's why I like image so much I
can plug a lot I've developed a
character that's a receptacle for for
Larry you know he's got his own life too
I mean sometimes he says stuff that
breaks me up like he was talking about
begging and he said he says my might
he says my silent partner is the the
church my the church's job is to instill
guilt my job is to leverage it affects
their life and he's a beggar
you know Emmet said that I didn't you
know it's funny when you're right it's
the character also heads is two cents so
you've already written the screenplay
yeah okay how was it when you first
started like the first seven days I know
you'd had Emmitt in your mind for years
versus the last week of finishing that
screenplay it's all the same to me it's
just different stages but it's all
writing it's just you write differently
the first way you do it to me is I just
write it's really it's it's really funny
but very common I guess the
psychologists you know your subconscious
keeps track your subconscious is like I
read in a book that your subconscious is
like the keel you don't see it it's
underneath the water but it keeps you
steady you know that's what keeps the
sail from it's the keel that the
pressure so the subconscious so I start
to just write stuff down anything that
occurs to me you know maybe maybe my car
gets stolen I'll just write anything I
know about cars being stolen or stealing
or cars or but you just write a whole
list and other writers do this too I and
it's not unique to me but you just keep
writing as the ideas flow until you
finally got right I don't do this
anymore I put it away and then I read it
and as you start to read it you see
there's a holy cow there's a theme here
certain ideas in different forms either
car or
or guitar or there's a theme and so you
follow the theme in other words it now
the writing tells you what to write oh
this is what my subconscious is really
talking about when I'm what I think is
just blathering on a piece of page you
know so you just follow that so that's
the next stage you just follow the what
the writing is telling you and then you
explore that then you read that at least
that's what I do and it starts to become
into a solid and then and then you try
to look what's the the the substructure
of the story because of the facts that
are related become a story that one
person tells me that may have started
with divergent people but then all
smooshes into Emmett and he's on this
trip and then I put him on a road or
something or I put him in a house and
that and then this so the story comes
but how I write is different in each
stage so I keep interested I don't just
work on one kind of thing for three
months you know and sometimes I just put
it in a drawer and walk away you know
and this pitch rehearsing for this you
know I would I got a little hand camera
you know and so I would pitch to the
camera and then I would listen to it may
God type it out see what I remembered
from the pitch do it again and I was
learning how to pitch okay you know
these points are important then you want
to remember this but I was learning
about the story I was I was I said well
man I've told myself this story that the
screenplay is that I'm trying to get 96
pages into five minutes or four minutes
but I'm learning more about the story so
when I go home and and the couple of
people said okay send me this the
screenplay I'm gonna change a little
because I've told the story so many
times rehearsing for this that I saw Wow
the story is actually a lot sharper and
tighter now so I can go home and edit so
it's a process it's always a process you
know it's like some painters never fin
painting you know the the artistry Walt
he would sell you a painting and then
five years later he'd knock on your door
and he'd say can I have the painting
back I want to change the red I mean the
painting was never finished you know you
had to agree to that when you bought the
painting and I may come back in five
years I mean okay does Emmett ever get a
steady roof over his head yeah that's
the that's the the the TV version
there's a TV version where he's a
homeless character like like Charlie
Chaplin where he's a neighborhood Venice
Beach so I took the motorcycle away from
him he's got this funky old motorcycle
with a sidecar
I took the motorcycle away from him and
I just wanted to nail him down for the
sitcom it's a one camera but that was
about two I guess other people you know
you would want to make it cheap and keep
him one place so so yeah he became
homeless when I took the motorcycle away
and I put him on a bicycle and so he but
now he saves people like Chaplin did or
like basically its louis c.k without the
two daughters in the apartment
you know he he just takes care of things
he takes care of people if you got your
shoes stolen he'll find him somebody
breaks into your store he'll beat up the
guy if he's if there's a you know bully
like Chaplin there he saves the girl and
he's looking for you know love and a
place to stay the difference is that
what he's looking for is a home and
somebody to love or care for but he also
finds out that he functions best as an
outsider and that's a kind of attention
which I think Chaplin had he wouldn't
keep a job for long what's what's
interesting about that outsider
why do you relate you can you can
function because that came from a
discussion that happens director a long
time ago when I was doing the Emmett
show i have a show and so i was talking
to the director and
I said he said why is it homeless and I
said I don't know why is Charlie Chaplin
homeless and he said well you tell me
why is Charlie Chaplin homeless and we
both came to the conclusion that Wow
he wants to be homeless he functions
best you haven't there's a certain
freedom and I mean like even in a
marriage a lot of people are freer in
the marriage because I don't know they
bought he below he he Emmett is a
survivor he functions as a survivor
he's like an alley cat or like a
cockroach I mean that's what they do you
know some some things are best left wild
you know they function best that way
what did you learn about your method of
pitching you'd said you were a little
nervous at one point and you felt you
rushed it or said something well you
know I started out basically at heart
I'm a stand-up comedian that's how I
started I used to open for Woody Allen I
mean I was very successful at it and as
a stand-up comedian or stands come you
you read the audience becomes an
instinct maybe you're born with it I
mean I think I was because I just am a
natural storyteller but a funny story
teller and you you listen you you find
out because I never wrote anything when
I was a stand-up comedian I never wrote
and know how to write I mean you give me
a white piece of paper and I would
freeze when I would do is I would get up
on the stage and I would talk about my
my day or something that happened to me
you know that I thought was funny then I
told my friend and I'll tell you and the
coffee house is back in the day and you
listen to what the audience laughs at
what they're interested in you can feel
it or hear it and after a while it
becomes a learned instinct that you
would have a photographic memory for
laughs I have a photographic memory for
laughs if I
entertained you or told you stories
about myself I would just be talking and
we were to be having a conversation kind
of one-sided but a conversation and if I
had to go up on the stage I could go up
on the stage and tell the same story I
told you but made it much shorter I
could tell the story just for the laughs
I would kind of my mind would kind of
well that's an instinct I have I don't
you know I don't write it down or Romero
try to remember where you left I know I
just tell the story and all the stuff
you didn't laugh at drops out and that's
how I worked as a stand-up comedian so
that's how I kind of it's it's kind of
an instinct you know you're just born
with it like you know comic timing you
you really can't teach that that's
something you're born with you know some
people are born musicians with some have
a perfect year pitch you know you just
go with what you know guess what's alike
looking back on what you've applied to
the story with Emmett what is something
or some things that you're almost
embarrassed to admit that weren't clear
to you on actually writing a script I
know you said you you kind of piece it
together from different things but what
is something that you've liked aha why
did why didn't I think of that earlier
it was so clear wow that's the story I
mean first of all I have ADHD so I have
been clueless most of my life I mean
even even now I will find out what I
learned or what was going on maybe a
year from now I used to be in the
committee which was a very hip you know
like I was in second city that was very
hip you know far reaching in great
satirical company but it took me ten
years to figure out wow we were so cool
I didn't think I was cool at all I was
just you know we were like training
Dobermans that's I mean we literally
said that out loud to ourselves we were
mr. Myerson mr. me
he was the director and owner of the
theater the committee and we were his
trained Dobermans he'd come in with a
newspaper and he said let's get Nixon
you know and I'd say well you know what
and he'd say well you know get up there
and improvise now you know we'll throw
some stuff you know blah blah blah and
then he would we would do that and he
would come back after yet ended a show
and he'd say yeah explore that part
about you know what you were talking
about there explored that so he would
and then so he would just do what he
said like trained dogs now he wasn't
writing the stuff because we were in
perhaps improvising on the States it was
coming out of us and he was kind of
guiding it so in a way it was our show
but but I didn't know that we really
didn't know how intelligent we were
until we came off the stage after making
everybody laugh well it took me 10 years
to figure out how funny I was I still
find that to be true that in 10 years
I'll find out how hit this here thing is
was that cool so I'm always in lag time
I I've given up trying to figure out
anything I just put one foot in front of
the other you know just you just keep on
going
don't look back if you were gonna give
another screenwriter a pep talk let's
say they were coming to story Expo 2015
and maybe they were nervous we heard
from a couple of people that there were
some people that were nervous right what
would your pep talk be to that
screenwriter don't be nervous okay it's
first of all it doesn't serve anything I
mean maybe it does it helps you prepare
maybe well nervous that they prepare so
you're prepared but you can prepare
without being nervous so nervous has
nothing to do with it but I find that
I've always been right artistically and
maybe not among other people but
artistically I've always been right
maybe I didn't have enough chops
so keep writing or keep drawing you know
I got paint also but but keep keep doing
it and always try to be better and
always try to do your best but don't
listen to other people well I guess you
can listen but you have to do what they
say and that's I guess the difference
you know listen I've always been right
and I found out every other person has
always been right who's been successful
successful people are right a priori one
of the great things about about pitching
my rehearsal back at home is I said okay
what's the core of the clown what's the
core of the clown and that I had to go
what's the core of Chaplin what's the
core of any clown no doubt clowns have
no doubt that's why they're funny I mean
they hit a challenge and they they hit a
wall they get stopped but they don't
they don't Chaplin once he stopped just
goes in another direction but he doesn't
back up and go God you know they they
they get over they get over they don't
get over it they get over it keep going
forward I remember Tarantino said some
of the most brilliant thing you know
directory he said well hey you know how
do you just keep going he says I think
of myself as a pac-man you know that
game pac-man he said I think of myself
as a pac-man I can't go back I can only
go forward any huge bites cool thank you
mr. Tarantino so that I just keep that
in mind there's no doubt man you just
keep going you and and maybe you're not
good enough now for this but as long as
you get better just keep on going that
that's all so you know I learned I'm not
saying you can't learn that's why I'm
here to learn how to pitch you know but
there was never a time when someone just
crushed you oh yeah all the time my
parents close friends
I mean everybody yes I did I and then
that that was that was the tragedy I
listened to these stupid people I
remember a therapist once said I was
complaining about my father and he first
of all he the first thing he said was
God I said God what he said
that parents tell their kids is
unbelievable he said every kid that
comes in here he said they're fine it's
their parents that are crazy but
I can't tell them that because I'll stop
taking the kid a year so you know the
best I can do is protect the kid from
who from their parents it's parents who
up kids kids don't themselves
up you're born cool you know and then
Slayers come on you so you know
obviously after a while I learned
because I try to do it their way I try
to do it my parents when I try to do it
my teachers way I try to do it everybody
else's way and it never worked so I
thought hey let me try it in my way and
I found out AI was a lot happier and
gradually I became better and more
affirmed the world affirmed you know
throw that one hand up and the universe
slaps it you know but that takes a lot
of learning it's not easy